when jackass forever premieres in
theaters on february 4th it will mark
the fourth movie in the jackass
franchise in the first since 2010's
jackass 3d as usual it will feature
wall-to-wall death-defying stunts and
gross-out gags without getting into
spoilers this new film should give
jackass fans everything they love and
more one way the movie will be different
than its predecessors is that the main
cast has gotten bigger even better some
famous faces will be showing up
including musician machine gun kelly and
comedian eric andre it makes sense that
jackass is adding some new blood given
how much has already been spilled over
the years many of the stars are now
firmly middle aged and the toll on their
bodies is more and more difficult to
shake off in johnny knoxville's case one
stunt from jackass forever convinced him
to hang up the vans at least for now
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
knoxville spoke about the stunt in a new
interview with variety while he didn't
get into specifics for spoiler reasons
the stunt involved doing a magic trick
in a bullring he explained i wanted to
prank an animal and that's what we came
up with the bull wasn't amused and
plowed into him flipping him over and
knocking him out cold a preview of the
stunning moment is featured in the
latest trailer for the upcoming movie to
boot jackass forever director jeff
tremaine said of knoxville he was
snoring for three or four minutes it was
gnarly the bull did not appreciate it
and just
absolutely smoked me worse than i've
ever got smoked in my life by a bull
according to the publication paramedics
arrived and loaded knoxville into the
ambulance when they asked him who the
president was knoxville replied obama
which was unfortunately incorrect given
that filming occurred in december 2020.
he then joked to variety maybe because
that's who i was wishing for please
please obama knoxville is no stranger to
injuries but even for him the damage was
pretty severe a broken wrist a broken
rib a concussion and a brain hemorrhage
when asked whether it was his first
hemorrhage he couldn't remember after
leaving the hospital the jackass
ringleader worked with a neurologist to
recover his cognitive skills which took
about three months in the meantime
jackass forever producers in knoxville
agreed to scrap the rest of the stunts
planned for the film knoxville noted
that the thought of putting himself back
in harm's way was no longer an option he
went on to say my family doesn't like me
doing this type of thing this is the
most wicked bull hit i've ever taken
it's arguably for the best that johnny
knoxville is moving away from performing
stunts electrocution is so so i had a
blowout fracture in my left eye on a
stunt where my eye popped out the bull
stunt in the upcoming jackass forever
feature is just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to stunts the stars put
himself through for the sake of good
entertainment value and although fans
have no doubt enjoyed watching knoxville
test his limits on camera he certainly
paid the price for doing so from a
physical standpoint
can you feel my heart
wow
in september 2021 nova legal funding put
together a list of the cost of medical
treatments necessary to treat a variety
of serious injuries knoxville has
sustained over the years on jackass
according to the group's estimations on
their sites knoxville has had somewhere
in the neighborhood of twenty five
thousand dollars worth of hand stitches
additionally thirty thousand dollars has
been spent on face stitches his crotch
injuries have cost a total of roughly a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars and
the broken hand and rib injuries have
racked up approximately two hundred
thousand dollars in medical bills
respectively among the more exotic and
costly injuries nova legal funding
included in their list was an alligator
bite that they say cost knoxville 100
thousand dollars to care for as well as
a brain hemorrhage which the jackass
star potentially spent upwards of two
million dollars to treat when you add
these to a whole slew of other injuries
he sustained knoxville is estimated to
have paid nearly 8.7 million dollars to
put himself back together good times
with all of his injuries including that
wicked jackass forever bull stunt behind
him knoxville sounds like he's more than
ready to watch his friends go to the
extreme from the sidelines while
speaking with variety he declared i've
done enough i don't have anything to
prove i have kids to raise that's the
most important thing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]